[Applaudissements]
ça m'arrive démâtage d'élèves du coup de
salut bonjour je mange des frites loops
je risquais bronze mehdi bou said and
est né en algérie il a grandi à laval et
maintenant il fait rire tout le québec
avec un premier spectacle à son image
demain parce que c'est un spectacle qui
parle de demain c'est un spectacle parle
de ma vision de demain
ma vision du québec ma vision du monde
de demain donc le et c'est aussi premier
mot que j'ai appris en français je
parlais pas français quand je te remets
ici
ceci n'est pas une pipe se suit les pas
de marteau et ceci n'est pas au pays
diplômé il y à peine six ans de l'école
nationale de l'humour
mehdi bou said and s'est rapidement
taillé une place à la télévision grâce à
vrak jeu le rendez vous se lève petit
lait cru
et au cinéma on l'a vu dans de père en
flic de rencontre est la fille la plus
dynamique depuis un an de suivi adoré
d'un jeune public
l'humoriste de 27 ans entretient une
relation privilégiée avec ses fans sur
les médias sociaux
ils vivent littéralement ma journée avec
moi tout ce que je fais je leur montre
puis mes cris fusent répond veut avoir
une image positive pour les jeunes que
je vous donnais je veux donner ce que ce
que moi on va donner mais ton camp quand
j'ai regardé mais ce rapport de
proximité
mehdi bou said and les cultive aussi en
donnant des ateliers d'écriture aux
jeunes et en présentant son spectacle
dans des prisons cellphone jouer dans
une prison où c'est le fun de jouer dans
un sous sol d'église au burkina faso au
tc nous c'est ça qui me fait triper
j'apprends beaucoup plus de queue
apprennent de moi c'est pas grand chose
a été faite par un vieux coach russe sur
le live sur scène c'est avec une grande
aisance que mehdi bou said and parle
d'ouverture d'inclusion et de différence
et il réussit drôlement bien à faire
passer son message
mon père est algérien et ma mère ne
savait pas voilà ses oeuvres ici julie
jasmin bouderont radio canada montréal
[Applaudissements]